you guys I'm gonna get out there and
probably do a good job that was bindi
Irwin 'z attempt at smack-talking the
opposing team during Monday night's
group dance competition on Dancing with
the Stars really good bindi one thing
you maybe maybe weren't perfect at was
talking smack in the group rehearsal you
could not bad
she was so bad et caught up with the 17
year old after the show to give her a
chance to redeem herself okay I started
actually really like cheese
I don't know right but I think it's just
cuz how I would say for the home field
TV it's kind of a good point that was
good smack talk bindi and Derrick earned
a perfect score for their creepy
Argentine tango Derrick admitted he
didn't like asking bindi to embrace her
sexy side I asked her to give like my
like hey I want you to give you the
spheres I said the words sexy and I was
like I ain't say that bring you bindi
but this she's like oh okay well I'll
try yeah sure and then up at the music
on she's like oh my whoa whoa okay young
lady you're allowed to do that for about
a half and then a song finishes you go
back to be my little bindi okay